a California man armed with an AR-15 is
shot and killed by police after refusing
to drop his weapon officials now say he
was surrounded with nearly 50 weapons
he'd obtained illegally including
multiple ghost guns and a mannequin
dressed like a soldier we want me to do
this is his gun just bring it back with
you send it over here to the side
sir
I'm sitting on this chair
on June 28th Richmond California police
officers executed a search warrant at
the home of 63-year-old Jose Martinez at
the time Martinez was already in police
custody for illegal gun possession
making criminal threats and brandishing
a weapon responding officers executed a
search warrant at Martinez's home to
collect multiple weapons he wasn't
supposed to have
garage doors and he has
Burger
camera video shows officers approach the
home and announce themselves
restaurant Police Department search one
demand entry
Richmond Police Department
search warrant demand and trade
thank you
Richmond Police Department search
foreign
[Music]
officers determine a door is open they
walk inside it's
it's negative
yes this is open
wide open
Target contact great come back here come
back
come back here it's the police Richmond
Police Department
hey police stand up and come this way
inside officers come in contact with an
elderly woman
yeah
could you come up could you come back
here
they're not acknowledging
push
they're deep in the house
step
Richmond Police Department can you hear
me
it looks like a through and through hold
it
push up the palm
I'm gonna lock on the stairwell
through all right yes I'll walk left
left
remind me of double blockers and then
the recitation pursue so we're blocking
left and right all right we're blocking
left and right next to go contact
officers head upstairs
can be heard calling for a man named
Kevin to come down the man was later
identified as 66 year old Kevin McDonald
Richmond police anybody upstairs come
down now
where's Kevin
Kevin if you're up there come down down
here
Kevin this is the Richmond Police
Department
take a team of four hold the stairs
we're taken right or your guys's left
it looks like the score
which way are we going movies way
holding the stairs I need one more
from the outside
copy for critical Andy
yes sir it's on you guys
push me please
oh hallway Open Door straight ahead
I'm gonna block left
all right
Richmond police
video then shows officers search a room
upstairs
foreign
here we go guys
all right
are you guys code four in that bedroom
go ahead let's put it on this let's go
over here
hang on
you're good Rob
OT
is it good yeah okay when the room is
determined to be clear an officer makes
his way to the Next Room
yep wait hold on all right here we go
the officer can be heard calling for
McDonald's to drop the weapon when he
refuses two officers open fire Richmond
police
after the shooting an officer approaches
McDonald
let's go what's good as officials assess
the room more weapons can be seen on
body camera video in all investigators
found a live grenade thousands of rounds
of ammunition and 48 firearms in the
bedroom including pistols revolvers
rifles and shotguns among those weapons
17 were ghost guns meaning they did not
have serial numbers we want me to do
this is his gun just bring it back with
you send it over here to the side
thank you
I'm sitting on this chair make sure
there's nothing else I don't I don't
think so
video captures officers surveying the
room and working to bring McDonald Aid
me and you cut it
hey it's a move to the floor
hey should we move them to the floor tom
104. a firm on a patrol response if it's
clear to the Watch Commander
this
who's got uh who's got gloves rubber
gloves
well talk to her secure her yeah there's
rubber gloves
all right
um
you and me downstairs yes
hey I need a secondary search on all
bedrooms
yes we're gonna start from up here
you okay yeah good after the shooting
the involved officers walk outside
nope my public safety statement is we
fired in the mail down the hallway no
business
only Direction was down that Corridor I
don't know if rounds came out I believe
they did it looks like they exited that
house right there so let's check this
side uh
I'm gonna take care of that yep
McDonald was pronounced dead on the
scene the officer involved shooting is
now under investigation by both the
Richmond police department and the
Contra Costa County District Attorney's
Office reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie